there you go you see
after months of negotiation sky news was
told to meet this car in western romania
and to follow the passengers wouldn't
communicate or reveal themselves
and the car a beaten up old jeep had no
plate or any identifying features
in a forest clearing we met the weapons
dealers
armed balaclava and in military clothing
they were deeply suspicious and wary
throughout
on orders from the head of the gang they
showed us the types of weapons they
supply
the vast majority go to western europe
and they boast
the supply is virtually endless
semi-automatic these are high quality
weapons
smuggled from ukraine into romania and
then abroad
demand they say is absolutely huge
the biggest seller the ak-47 the weapon
of choice of terrorists
not ordinary criminals okay this is the
small
charger with 10 10 bullets
and they're with 30 bullets
just the example yeah yeah
yeah because the the ak has a
traditional sort of the the
whatever you know
also never never never broke down these
weapons yeah and the very er
yeah you can drop them you can you know
and that's why it's one of the most
popular weapons worldwide because it is
so strong
yeah small you can you can hide it hide
it yeah yeah
you can use it with one hand you know
you
okay yeah yeah and it's sniping now this
is that
explain to us this because it's quite a
specialist weapon
300 meters
like this 300 meters right and this
you can the advantage is you can shoot
the target from
from like far away from far away yeah
and what is the maximum range on that
300 meters is good for what's
that maximum is like
500 yeah but 300 you must be good
is it possible that the weapons these
weapons end up in the hands of what we
call terrorists as opposed to
criminals if you have the money he
doesn't care who you are
you're gonna sell to anyone
the increase in murderous terror attacks
in europe has highlighted
the damage that can be done by
military-grade weapons in the hands of
individuals as well as gangs
europe is awash with illegal weapons
traditionally terrorist attacks were
characterized by the use of bombs
not anymore automatic weapons kill more
people
and are easier to use and from the
fighting in the middle east jihadists
are returning
fully trained across europe and the
united kingdom security services
are on a constant alert every single day
the potential for what we've seen in
europe in terms of
a greater availability and use of those
kind of weapons we're very conscious of
the fact that
that's only 21 miles away across the
channel and so we
we are uh constantly working and
vigilant in terms of managing that
threat as it
poses to itself to the uk 1700
euros networks of these mafia inspired
gangs stretch from the balkans to
eastern europe
virtually anything is available to
anyone if they're prepared to pay
there's a going concern amongst uh
police authorities across
europe that crime gangs are now the main
suppliers
of weapons not just to criminal groups
in the west but also to terrorists both
in western europe and
in the middle east that means islamic
state could get their hands on weapons
like this
as well and this is just a shop front if
you like
it's just a small truck with a an array
of guns for sale
they insist though they can supply as
much as anyone could ever want
the gun runners said they weren't
bothered by local law enforcement as the
weapons weren't used in romania
and they're just exporters insisting we
stayed for 20 minutes while they left
they told us that the next time we
arrived they expected us
to be buyers stuart ramsey sky news
romania